okay four people joining us today we are
looking at finance functionality for
which is going in to version 12 or from
language so this is primarily supporting
two forms of Bloomberg data access and
one for Reuters data access but there is
infrastructure necessary to do that and
it involves the functions service
request service submit and so on now
have these been knitted into other pages
and so on or what and where did this
documentation come from did who wrote
this oh this guy wrote part of it
this is faheen yeah yes we did net it I
think we had a meeting about it and I
think these are NetID okay good so we've
already gone through these pages oh yes
but we would like a final approval ofit
well have you mean do I have to read
everything or this is it can you tell me
what's different but there is nothing
different it's just is this does
continuous task stuff work our for
Bloomberg terminal and Reuters link it
does work okay for others it will just
give an error message of it's not
supported okay and the last time we
spoke we needed a method of saying that
these particular service pages will work
only for what from finance platform was
that resolved I cannot
overt I thought there was a talk about
it but I am NOT following up on it okay
so who is and how is that gonna work
IIIi don't know wait what I'm sorry it's
whose project managing this and how are
they I am so I can't follow that I don't
know okay what are we trying to do here
okay so the plan is to have these in the
main documentation with a note that says
they're only available in finance
platform is that correct yes that's
right yeah we already have a meeting
with Arnold he knows he knows and
there's the problem okay so what a
service response and that doesn't seem
to have been defeat rised lost spoke
there was no reason for it to exist and
therefore I have future eyes dead okay
all right fine is it referenced anywhere
else I
yes it's referenced okay so we will have
to remove it yes well if you don't
believe it this has any reason to exist
why don't you I will remove it I will
remove it okay well yeah it's real
simple we just go here we go to page
status and we say excised and kaboom
it's gone I mean it still archived but
it's gone um okay so this also mentions
service response which we don't need
okay so what's to look at next so we
want to look specifically at these
service service connection pages right
oh yes yes we really should take a look
at it because a few things have changed
and of course I can't run any of the
stuff that's right right okay so with
respect to the examples um that means
those examples have to be locked
otherwise the system will try and rerun
them right yes but that hasn't been done
here no I I don't know how to but maybe
okay so
let's get brian on the phone if we could
can somebody get Brian yes you do it by
putting in this content status lockdown
and so on okay okay this is not exactly
our standard way of do it why is there a
wiseass and red here this is entity
value it's coming from entity value I
why is it in red I was told that this is
fixed but apparently not okay and this
is particularly
the usage for entity value might have
changed I I know but but but I'm saying
if this is correct
it's either correct or it's not correct
well it works and so that's not good
enough
if this is not a correct documented form
for entity value we cannot use it well
that used to be document okay so is it
still documented or not it seems like it
has it's change that's what I'm worried
about
okay though I think it's wrong okay so
so what okay this is Alan here I'm here
I've seen that if you're talking about
the read on the entity Association yeah
is that is that it currently yes I don't
think that's correct I think it's a bug
I thought it was being addressed
but I don't see documentation in entity
value I don't see documentation for that
third argument in entity value at all
does entity value have a third argument
or not yes it it has for as long as I
have been using entity value so if
that's been removed I don't know who
removed it or so it doesn't appear to be
documented in uh in here right I I agree
I can't see it there that does not seem
right to me okay fine all right
okay so I'll talk to Tony and see what
yeah fine so it probably needs another
entry there for what is that it's the
yeah so I think that's a as you say it's
a bug in the documentation of entity
value now I mean this is one of the most
unbelievably complicated I mean okay is
this a standard way of documenting a
service connection with just examples
and more examples well the problem is
that this is doing something new and the
new stuff is that this is one of the
only services
that has entity interface to it it
suppose continuous tasks and so that
there is no precedence for how to
document such a thing okay where are you
putting it on this page have you put it
on this page or not so now okay so we
need to do that so the name of that
service is Bloomberg terminal where
should we put it to a button underneath
business services perhaps yes
it doesn't just quite Fred but I don't
see any other section for it well well
we could do finance X clue could we have
another section
let's put it under here
it's called financial information okay
so here we would say Bloomberg terminal
[Music]
access to Bloomberg well actually okay
maybe we should move this down a bit
maybe we'll just put it at the bottom
since it's accessible only um okay so
often Phi
form shall become a link and drea that's
for you to figure out okay hello
as she is on mute get off mute please
okay if she's not there then no I'm here
I'm here
okay did you understand what I said that
needs to be a link yes okay so I don't
know how these okay so how do we
describe what this is good yes I access
to Bloomberg terminal data no no because
we got to say that you have to have a
Bloomberg terminal license right yes it
should be up and running on your Windows
machine so access to Bloomberg terminal
windows only yes okay let's look at the
other ones here why was it um I have
this there we go
this applies to any machine is that
correct yes and that's supported on all
platforms is it all Bloomberg terminal
data yes
access to Bloomberg data license yes
data that right I mean is that some
specific subset oh yes it's that they're
a different service of fetching data
from them so it's not real time okay so
let's say that
real-time Bloomberg terminal data yeah
access to stored Bloomberg data license
data right
sounds a bit awkward but was it correct
yes what the awkwardness is the fact
that the word data comes up twice yeah
don't worry about it so what is the
Reuters one Reuters is also a real-time
what platforms Windows and Linux
what a mess okay
okay does this need to get put on pages
about it does need to get put on the
financial data one second oh boy this is
still not updated Alan for your stuff
right no not yet okay so I think we need
a thing here financial data services so
this is mostly
execute is that right or are all you can
use service execute correct yes you for
certain services yeah these services can
use it yes for all of them okay
I kind of think we should just link to
that page and not really go into more
detail here um
um do we want to mention here
asynchronous delivery of these things or
not bother if people think that's
important then I seem to think it is
important no no but this is a page about
financial yes none of the other services
on there actually do that do that of
course I understand that but we're
talking about financial data services
here I think we say what will we say
that a real-time streaming oh no no no
what are you talking about what you're
talking about how service submit works
yeah yes that's nothing to do with
real-time streaming that's to do with
connecting or do you have real-time
streaming with ourselves a subnet no no
I'm not talking about that I'm talking
about what we say here I think we should
just leave it like this okay okay let's
go back and look at this
connect your Bloomberg terminal account
okay um and this needs to say well I
mean so somewhere here and I don't know
how to write it oh my gosh that wasn't
very useful was it um this needs to say
have a cell that basically says um no
that's gonna that's gonna go group
incorrectly okay make sense did you go
to see what I'm saying I'm trying to put
a cell above this one don't understand
okay so no that's it's no no look when
the page gets built none of the stuff
above will ever show up do you get what
I'm saying on the build page right so
let's take a look at one of these here
that's not the build page this is still
the old version I don't know why that
looks really weird okay this is the
built page so I don't know where we want
to write here wolf and phones platform
only I think maybe it goes in brackets
after this okay because what Arnold and
Brian were suggesting is to put a stripe
so what we asked designed to find do you
have a mock-up of it we send a request
to design already okay what would the
text of that stripes a little bit chucks
okay
no this should just say forget this
thing here just remove that line there's
a stripe then that then that's all there
is to it okay but I didn't have a stripe
so okay fine but that's what you're
supposed to be getting so let's take
that out
you must have an act of
description okay so make sure these
things are links to the appropriate
places make sense yes are we considering
this is an experimental feature or non
experimental at this point I don't see
any good reason it should be
experimental do you know I don't think
it should be experimental we kind of
want to support it
you
you
what is the stuff that says entity look
up I don't understand that at all
this is how entity lookup actually works
you give it no no no no I don't I I'm
talking about how the documentation is
set up yes I don't know that was a
question and so when we discussed the
service we wanted an entity interface to
it but we didn't know where to document
it well that doesn't seem like a great
place to me so where would we document
it I'm not sure I request thought yes
Allen there's going to have to be a
whole discussion about um access next
maybe we should say data feeds and
entities because this page is going to
have to mention entity someplace as well
right I mean we just haven't gone to
this yet it that could I presume it's
gonna be the same thing we've been doing
other places and I would hope so okay
the see also here obviously should point
to Bloomberg data license and I don't
know how
work to get to financial data and and
the entity pages gender Stella I'm
saying that's Ana square for Brian and
so on Andrea got it what is this and
does it I understand what so this is the
set of four Reuters you have to connect
it using the VPN and so this will have
to be edited with fake username and
position and whatnot but connection
settings is how you the things you've
given here work from within our domain
is that correct yes but nowhere else
no okay okay no what you say entity
lookup so your invent a completely new
categories for these examples yes I am
doesn't seem right well I couldn't
pretty look up anywhere else okay first
of all although workflow pages about
these things I have not written any have
you asked for some to get written no I
have not asked but you understand why
they would be a good idea because yes oh
yes we used to have tutorials but yeah
and there are tutorials for Bloomberg
data Bloomberg terminal okay but yeah
you could convert this so those are
being converted to tech notes right oh
that's why so maybe there should be a
tech note for this no there should be a
workflow for this because like the
connection stuff should be in a workflow
I what is the difference between a tech
note and evokes it's just completely
different I mean look at them look at
two of them a workflow is this very
specific thing okay a very specific
thing that gives steps for how to do an
operation involves okay okay so that's
that that's the okay so like for example
here I don't know something like this
right there'll be some very specific
thing one two three four oh yes that
this is very useful okay I should be
writing this you okay yep so Philip
Bloom is the guy who knows how to do
this there Elizabeth shacked manages
them you know if you know the content
they can help you with the formatting of
this well that would be very nice yes
maybe Andre I could make note of it and
so this is what you need for you know
things like that if you want to give a
bigger picture then you need some kind
of tech note but this is for the you
know the sequence of steps to make
something happen like if for instance
you're you know connected to this fair
enough
okay so I don't know some properties
instruments and so these are things
formatted it's really hard to tell
what's going on this is the format that
has been with us for some time but if
you not gather okay look at Popkin for
example
okay
okay
you
all right so where are you showing the
submit stuff it's right there oh boy by
the way why are you using date objects
that look like this why aren't you using
the proper proper appearance of date
objects that's because it's fam manually
entered I could do control equal I guess
okay yeah I would kind of do control
equals actually okay well I'm changing
my mind I'm changing my mind I think
it's more obscure given that you've
actually got all the detail here of um
you know you've actually got the six
tuple of values all meaning something no
um get the first five Bloomberg terminal
properties and I um
this isn't quotes and alone isn't it's
just my oversight okay oh boy how are
you gonna make that dynamic welcome you
have to burn that in somehow okay
all right entity look up how do I even
know what entities are there there you
do entity properties right now what how
you know what entities are there you
reassumed they know what we do enter the
list won't show up because these are not
we because they always change and
remember keeps on changing them so we
can't have a prefetched list or can't we
touch in real time well there are ways
of doing that
but there are no ways to hook it up into
entity value framework so if there's no
it doesn't take a function when you
create a custom entity store what do you
mean it doesn't take a function so the
way entity lookup works is that for
entity property value we give it a
function which is a underlying service
execute right and for entity itself
there is no function that I say well
check
from Bloomberg if this particular entity
is right or not and we can't really how
do you document where you were you
documenting does the entity exists are
we we don't we just say whatever string
you want to put in you can and then if
it isn't working then you'll get an
error message directly from Bloomberg
rabbit is there a way of testing
programmatically I want to know whether
a a a is a valid ID or whatever yeah I
mean that will just give you no there is
no way okay so that body should be okay
and why don't we say name here okay
Bloomberg entity with a specified name
and if you can copy that on to the other
ones that would go okay um it's not an
entity lockup it's an entity property
lockup okay let's see entity value
actually let's say
it's a really entity value it's not
necessarily lookup and it might be going
out and
[Music]
let's see entity values maybe now yeah
that's much more precise
okay okay so here um Bloomberg
Blumberg entities are automatically
mapped to off language entities for
immediate lookup or something it's
alright immediate or asynchronous lookup
so make any sense I I'm sorry I can't I
don't know what that means
okay so I'm trying to explain here that
Bloomberg entities right yes so we are
talking like MSFT US equity and what no
yes right okay I see you're fair enough
fair enough I don't know if why are you
saying asynchronous lookup well isn't
that what so submitters service submit
is exactly that yes okay that's what I'm
saying okay um okay so there's a few
things then that you should move over
from this one to the other ones yes yep
let me look at this other one we'll have
to remove that cell and I have to write
a Ethier is Reuters it's used to be
called Reuters ETA
okay so you're gonna do
with these these don't look right for
the those should be in quotes and so on
I suspect but I mean that the there's
some details here that don't look right
you need help from the documentation
folk like Brian okay to sort this out I
wish I could try just running these
things but I don't have I mean you will
be able to run bloom the data license
actually right now I could just run it
now you have to install the certificate
for it but well once the workflow is
released I you will be able to do that
okay okay I mean this looks great I mean
I know it's been a lot of work to get to
this point I don't see that I think
structurally this is okay nobody's gonna
understand it without the workflows and
things I'd write some somebody new but
yeah it's V actually can I ask you for
some kind of need a proper data
structure for storing tables I know this
is not the right group to talk to about
but that would be nice
what would type of tables I'm just a
very very long table with column names
and row names that's because it's very
heavy right it's for tech data that's
not the okay so that's a good use case
that you should talk to Chris Carlson
about because he's working on the
religion of data set it also probably
relates to the revision of time series
which is being done by different people
but he should know who's doing that